but first guns God and the grace to
listen that's the focus of tonight's
angle high school students parents
brothers sisters raw emotion suffering
sacrifice bravery heartache evil sorrow
anger 17 dead no more placing
nonsensical politics above our lives
no more accepting donations from the NRA
who seem to care more about their right
to own a gun than the lives of American
children
when did politics and money from the NRA
become more important than our lives our
message is simple and it's never again
well people want quick solutions they
want action they also want answers as to
how a 19 year old with a serious mental
illness can slip through the cracks how
did the FBI not follow up on obvious red
flags how the shooter had access to a
weapon despite his obvious mental health
issues it's all infuriating and beyond
upsetting and at the White House today
the president brought parents and
students and teachers together who were
grieving from parkland and from other
terrible tragedies right here also in DC
he let everyone have their say I was
lucky enough to come home from school
unlike some of my other classmates and
teachers this solution is not going to
be a singular thing it's gonna be
multifaceted and it's gonna be
created by a collection of different
people working together and we all have
to realize that we all have our opinions
and together we're going to be able to
work to a solution well said the
conversation now has turned to banning
ar-15 style weapons guns that have been
called assault weapons or weapons of war
now I don't understand why I could still
go in a store and buy a weapon of war an
AR I was reading today that a person 20
years old walked into a store and bought
an ar-15 in five minutes with an expired
ID how is it that easy many of you
remember the last time we had an assault
weapons ban it was from 1994 to 2004 the
study of the ban that was done by the
National Institute of Justice concluded
that the ban produced no discernable
reduction in the lethality and injurious
nough son violence it went on to note
that assault weapons were rarely used in
gun crimes even before the ban look
there are close to 15 million ar-15
style rifles in the United States today
it's one of the top-selling style of
weapons in the country and it may be
hard to believe especially after last
week these guns are actually rarely used
to commit violent crimes according to
the FBI rifles of all kinds not just the
AR semi-auto type accounted for just 3%
of firearms homicides in 2016 while
handguns accounted for 65% and contrary
to what you hear in the media handguns
are also still by far the weapon of
choice for mass shooters depending on
the definition it's when three or four
more people are killed now don't take it
from me even left-wing media outlets you
see the graphic there from things like
Mother Jones in its own review of the
mass shootings from 1982 through 2012
found that 66% of the weapons or
handguns while just 14% would qualify as
assault weapons according to the
definition
used by gun control advocates and now
writing in Reason magazine
Jacob solemn he affirms that banning
assault weapons will simply not stop
mass killings rioting politicians
activists and journalists who have
decided to blame mass shootings on
assault weapons either do not
acknowledge these facts or wave them
away it is clearly possible to carry out
attacks similar to last weeks without
using assault weapons nine of the mass
shootings with the twenty highest death
tolls involved handguns or long guns
that are not covered by the Feinstein
bill that includes the third deadliest
mass shooting which killed 32 people at
Virginia Tech in 2007 as well as two
other attacks that killed 17 or more
people GQ magazine not exactly a
conservative outlet address the same
issue a few years ago and it agreed
noting that even the Democratic staffers
who wrote the now expired 1994 federal
assault weapon ban knew it was a largely
symbolic policy perhaps the most
poignant words today came from a father
Andrew [ __ ] who buried his daughter
meadow just a few days ago flanked by
his sons his rage and his frustration
was evident all the school shootings it
doesn't make sense fix it should have
been one school shooting and we should
have fixed it and I'm pissed because my
daughter I'm not gonna see again she's
not here she's not here law work
together and come up with the right idea
and it's school safety it's not about
gun laws right now the focus should be
on school security the soft targets that
are so vulnerable today arming staff who
are well-trained getting authorities on
the state local and federal level to see
the obvious warning signs and act on
them and this obvious fact that America
has become a Society of strangers
through social media all those anonymous
insults and condemnation
we're often unduly harsh and
disconnected we must create a culture of
connectedness we must create a culture
in which our classmates become our
friends every single one of these school
shootings have been from young men who
are disconnected and let's not discount
this fact that while schools obsess
about diversity
sometimes that only breeds tribalism and
social media as I mentioned creates not
a community but a forced distance a
sense of longing even envy so maybe it's
time to listen to what Steve Scalise
said last week when I spoke to him just
hours after the shooting in parkland
prayer works he said getting back to the
basics
common sense family friendships and
belief that God loves us all no matter
what we're going through
think about that JROTC student Peter
Wang and what he showed us when he
sacrificed himself he was only 15 years
old but he helped save numerous fellow
students and teachers by first assuring
them to safety his training already
kicked in so admits all the cries for
change and legislation his example is
the one I hope more of us emulate the
president did a really good thing today
but as we seek to learn from these
horrific tragedies and fix what we can
emotion cannot and should not ever
override our Constitution we must
respect the rights that our Creator gave
us yes the second amendments right to
keep and bear arms and also our right to
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness those 17 students
and teachers or no longer with us they
don't have either of those rights not
the Second Amendment and not life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness
and that's the angle